it would he he would have laid it in it
would have tied the game that that that
was just an awful call plain and simple
106 to 103 is your final as the Lakers
advance to Vegas to take on the New
Orleans Pelicans Lakers now 10 and0 this
season when they take a lead to the
fourth quarter and they win this game
despite shooting
37% haven't won a game shooting that
poorly since
2016 but they do it tonight and Kenny
they are moving on to Las Vegas moving
on you know
two teams that are you know they don't
play at this level this early
consistently so you know that's been the
the um that's been the key word that's
been the Sesame Street word of the day
inconsistent or
consistency um you know for for the
Lakers so we'll we'll see what happens
when they get to Vegas uh we'll see if
they have this energy and this effort
that they have now they going to need it
um yeah but you know typically this
early in the season they don't always
they don't go five six games in a row
playing that kind of energy so we'll see
yeah it's going to be interesting to me
cuz the Pelicans obviously uh Brandon
Ingram Zion McCullum they're three
Allstars they're goingon to play but
their energy level D Collins always
talks about energy is one of the most
underrated talents in in because when
you watch herb Jones
alado you watch those guys play man they
bring it and that's what a bench is
supposed to do they're not supposed to
come out here and be a bunch of
superstars they're supposed to protect
the lead or get you back in the game so
the Lakers if they play like they did in
the second half and AD play like he did
the second half the Pelicans going to
beat them yeah ad finished with 27 and
15 he had
2 half okay heard do you heard that
before no I never heard that in in 12
years tonight Reeves gets the game ball
you know uh excuse me Reeves get the
game ball let me let me finish where you
interrupt me like youve been doing for
12 years Reeves gets the game ball ad
great first half 20 points seven in the
second half that 20 that he provided for
us in the second half that's supposed to
be what ad is supposed to do so Reeves
had a great game Off the Bench he's only
one in double fingers off the bench so
he gets the game ball tonight he matched
Phoenix Off the Bench with his 20 points
he gets it he gets it ahead of LeBron
see this I know what the hell I'm
talking no they can up Hey listen what
is that with with the Stu what the hell
I'm talking about yeah with the stuff
you don't know about basketball we can
write a book Reeves gets a game okay
LeBron you know LeBron hey me
too LeBron LeBron me too is able to play
that well down the stretch is just flat
out amazing I mean Reed played well but
man
LeBron at his age to to be there at the
end it's just uh it's incredible to
watch one guy played 40 minutes in this
game and it was LeBron James
unbelievable 318 and 11 the Los Angeles
Lakers earner spot the
semifinal first of all did my son's
covered if you would do anything about
it no he
didn't